hello everybody welcome to another
night of chess and psychology today is
tuesday october
6th oh my god it's already october um
so i am dorothy directory uh
been with you for a few months hopefully
you know by now
so um today i kind of decided to
just go over another dynamic game
surprisingly not topolo i am taking a
break from my
uh obsession with topalov's games so
we're going to take a break from topolof
but we are going to take a look
at a game that will happen between
tarash
and alohain and i am a big fan of both
of them i actually kind of tried to play
um tara's defense well i guess attack
as black it didn't go very successful
so yeah that'll be fun
all right so um i am reading a chat so
make sure you
type in and just i i really enjoy an
interactive class
so yeah let's do that also wow i think
this is the first time i'm saying that
the club has a 300 subscriber k
subscriber
i kind of i don't think i've seen that
before so
i think that might be new because i
remember that there was a 2.99 and i was
like huh
well i got three youtube accounts i
might as well sign up with
subscriber three of them but yeah
okay so i said chat is warming up a
little bit awesome great
so uh as i said this was a game between
taras and
alpine i can assume you all already have
a feeling
of uh well alejand is black we're
looking at this game from black so
most likely black did something pretty
cool you might be true
uh this game was actually played in 1922
uh that is kind of funny it's like
almost 100 years ago
kind of it's quite mind-blowing but all
right i'm gonna stop gushing
over oh hi uh
no no please don't bite my ipad and let
me get the microphone a little closer
so
all right i guess i have a pretty good
ish
setup uh let's assume okay
so um in this game
um i do believe that i have
talked about this uh blumenfeld idea
um it's like a mixture of different
openings but
the first time i actually um
heard about blumenfeld the c5 was there
was like in
my blooming dozen moscow opened 2015
i was um last round i was trying to
i was playing for a win but i didn't
choose my openings very wisely i was
when i like i didn't
i needed a win to get like my first or
second wgm
i am a wgm norm i already had like five
of wm so
yeah those are some fun memories and
surprise it didn't go as
planned uh this whole idea with d5 b5
and this a6 this was way way too sharp
for my taste
but that is something that uh if you
hide no
no no no well this will be fun to play
with championships with the cat
um but that that is the blumenfeld idea
so if you are
a sharp player and you want to give this
a try you're more than welcome to try it
it's quite sharp i had a pleasant game
but
i just missed my pawns too much and it
didn't really this is not necessarily
my style i don't really like to be
fighting
uh for i do like to play dynamic
but like i want to have like like a
awesome spatial advantage like a
super positional advantage and then just
convert that
to a dynamic advantage that's that's my
way
um compared to just you know playing
like tall
and giving up all my pieces and just
chilling
so this is one thing i just wanted to
mention about this blumenfeld just
if you are a big fan of gambits
here's something you can try um however
in this game it played it was played a
little bit differently
so it's still the same ideas with b5 but
just like a
just a slightly different move order but
again the ideas are
there one thing that could be
potentially different is that in
blumenfeld idea without e6 we could have
this g6 bishop g7 idea
so i'm just giving a small
opening introduction over here um so
all right let's just go back to the game
uh in the game
actually tarash took over here however
there are a bunch a bunch of other lines
you can do like
bishop g5 um i guess knight c3 might
also be interesting because the whole
idea is to try and do e4
so those are some of the things you
could consider so i kind of want to ask
um does anybody here
play this as white or black because then
we would have like a
more personal understanding
exactly if you don't know what to do
then blumenthal could be pretty
dangerous
uh for white yeah i agree um
i do think bishop g5 is interesting
but the problem with bishop g5 is well
what do i just take it over here you
could play knight c3 yeah this is
getting
this is quite interesting for both sides
um i could just take on
over here and just play d6 and that's
another
common ish plate white's gonna most
likely try to do stuff in the center and
king side i'm gonna do stuff in the
queen side so those are some of the
things that could be considered
um but yeah oh i see once
one or two people have played it okay
yeah
i don't think these are quite
interesting so
rock on okay b5
um so take now question
um what are we going to take it back
with i highly doubt
people will actually like to take it
with d because if you are going to
exchange queens and then you're going to
lose this bond and there's potential for
a4s and
i don't think we should do that um
so yeah i don't think we are gonna go
for that hi
tracy so tracy i actually had a very
interesting conversation so when we are
doing stuff on youtube
it's my understanding that leeches
doesn't matter doesn't care
religious only cares about twitch
correct me if i'm wrong
but i am not unleaches i'm on chess.com
i could switch to leeches eventually
i'm trying okay but
um oh flowers blue man yeah i this
the decorations i i
over ordered flowers over quarantine
because i was generally bored
so i and i ended up with really more
than i need so i just put them all over
the the house
so yes um that's one more thing to keep
in mind but the queen i5 will
that's interesting to mention but the
problem with queen a5
is bishop d2 if bishop d2 didn't exist
then i think queen a5 would have been
interesting with bishop d2 then you're
gonna move the queen again
and then this could also be happening so
yeah i don't think this is working
but uh so well no no no no don't show
no man showed the last game
what did i click yes yeah i don't like
chess.com
badchest.com give it give it
oh man well tracy i guess that was
karma for me not using leeches
i learned my lesson okay
um
all right i
there's some interesting questions but
i'm having a trouble understanding them
but
yes so my first question for you guys
well my first serious question before
that it was more rhetorical
um what do you think who do you want to
be why it's black and why
if you want to be white i can understand
why you got one more pawn
the potential of getting some stuff
happen in center
but
what do you want to do as black
if you're choosing to be black
oh uh yourself i do um yeah i do think
that was interesting too
if earlier bishop g5.05 could have been
a pretty decent response as well
but yeah while you guys are trying to
make a decision on well
who you want to be um so i'm sure most
of you have heard about
the whole uh stuff
with purchase link that's been going on
that's my team that um
sent the sentence archbishops um
got into a very unpleasant situation
where there was
some speculation and then it was proven
to be
correct so i don't have first-hand
information on that
but guess who does dennis borrows so
make sure you tune in for
the hour next after this one
so you're gonna enjoy some of that i
wish i could stay
and hear that too but i got a
neuroscience exam tomorrow
that i have to study for before i pass
out
uh yeah this past few weeks haven't
necessarily been
that awesome just way too much studying
when my sleeping schedule is oof
yeah so i think you guys are this i i
get that this position is quite
unfamiliar for most of you
but it doesn't mean that you can't make
a decision on
who you want like which side you prefer
so i personally
prefer black remember how i said i don't
like to do
like sacrifices uh necessarily yeah
that's
that's still valid but this is a kind of
a different situation because
in the position that i was mentioning
that i don't want to sacrifice i don't
want to be
uh i don't want to give up my pawn we
were talking about like this position
and yes acting bishop active bishop
uh but i i want to have this f-file i
want to have a serious
threat so in this position
this is where we're at right now we have
some serious ideas we got d5 coming up
this bishop could be activated most
likely through d6
castle and my rook is also doing awesome
so i
am quite um happy on this
so all right
um yeah we do have a center i think that
um those were some historical comments
that i don't think
anyone is gonna forget for at least next
few months to come
but yeah i i mean i'm sure everybody has
said
funnier or worse stuff so i'm not gonna
really
uh yeah okay
so i agree that we should do this d5
and while we're trying to do this idea
with d5 this is yeah exactly this is
kind of like a benko
but a little bit more um i want to say
improve
because now black got the center and has
the potential to attack in the king side
so yeah i think that's a little bit uh
improved compared to usual bankos
all right um yeah white does yeah you're
correct white does have these three
pawns in the queen side
however it's quite hard to actually put
them into good use especially because
these pawn uh not those two this one is
gonna be
also an easy target for black to try and
like poke around
but i okay honestly if we go into the
end game like a pawn and game then yes
i would be worried because i have less
pawn that pawn is quite advanced
but any time before that i'm not going
to really pay much attention to the fact
that i have less pawn
this respawn um this extra pawn for
whites would have been much more
stronger if whites was actually
had better piece coordination but white
doesn't really have that so
all right um
so we talked about how um
this pawn is not in the best
most prime position and okay so
uh here actually target for e3
um that's not the best choice g3 would
have been a more interesting choice
especially because after g3
um i think we're just thinking about it
a little bit more logically
black is definitely going to start
unleashing pieces on your king in the on
the king side
right so exactly white should try to
have better cover-up for the king than
just playing like a e3 then bishop d3
which this bishop is also always gonna
be under this
um under attack and
yeah i don't necessarily agree with this
bishop on d3 i feel like bishop on g2
i i can understand why it's not the
first thing that comes to
mind because well it's also not really
pinning anything attacking anything
we're most likely gonna do bishop b7
anyways
but yeah i agree axo i do think that
probably was uh
worried about losing on b5 and just
wanted to try its best and keep the pawn
that is a very valid hypothesis
okay so um yeah that's one thing that i
did want to mention was the difference
between e3 and g3
i did uh quite a lot of different games
on strategics people strategic
strategic super uh grand masters such as
cr
such as kappa blanca and i'm like caba
blanca would most
likely do something with g3 bishop g2
instead of e3
and that's another big difference that's
um
like usually players have this little
things that
you're either better in like dynamics or
in strategic but great chess players are
great at both
so if you do want to become a better
chess player
or a great chess player that's something
you should work on and don't just be
one-sided
i feel like for me i could work on my
dynamic understanding better i still
have a lot to improve
compared to my strategic understanding
so if you're playing with me you know
what to do
don't play me but yeah so
okay so we talk that's covered as well
yeah yeah i agree ourselves so
bishop d6 is nothing out of ordinary
we're just developing
bishop belongs on b7 um
what else can we think of so um
black does have a pretty awesome
development
and this position even though you have
this extra pawn is white it doesn't
bring you an
actual um actual understanding
of like okay your position is better
your position is
i don't think white is worse but white
is definitely not better i would say
black definitely has enough compensation
uh yeah spanish i don't necessarily
think dynamics means tactics it means
like
it's uh to me dynamic is not exactly
tactic it's like there's potential for
tactic
uh you have to always be watching out
for
like threats all around so a very active
position exactly
i think that's something to keep in mind
and yeah okay
so let's say uh white tries
his best to develop now i want to ask
you guys
whoa hi kitty what do you think
black should do so how are you going to
get your pieces out
and in close future i predict my cats to
be
jumping in front of the camera so i'm
giving you a heads up
like i don't pay attention to him from
five minutes and he needs the attention
like
even if i'm reading for my university
like i'm reading a book or something and
he has to come up
and he sleeps on the book so he he
takes away my attention he sleeps on the
laptop
he sometimes just puts his paw on my
phone it's
he's my boss basically um
i agree black has i want to say equalize
i would just say compensation and i
would definitely mention
that i want to be black right now
so yeah
i agree you gotta do knight d7 i didn't
i think 97
is the easiest way to go about this oh
no no please don't drop it
oh no well i was too late
um all right so i i completely do agree
with this
we do have to develop i agree with that
too very well said
um so white has to develop too
i do really enjoy the idea with queen e7
so
thank you one two three bunch of fours
and all right so now we have a somewhat
decent development for both sides black
definitely
has the upper hand in this position
even the white has this extra pawn but
it's you don't really you can't really
use this pawn
actually um while you guys are thinking
about a move
for black so black to move what do you
want to do
while you're thinking about it for those
of you who are
intermediate and thinking about well
what's different between an intermediate
and a beginner
is the whole concept of having extra
material
because i do have different private
students in different levels
and one of them is she's such a sweet
kid and um
like one of the things that i'm working
with her is just understanding the
concept that okay
just because you have an extra rook
doesn't mean you have to put it in like
a corner you need to
use it so even though it's such a simple
concept for everybody it's something
that we tend to forget
and we're like a piece up or pawn up and
we just
kind of feel great about it so keep that
in mind
uh it could it could get a little tricky
to actually actively think about these
and online chats and blitz chats but if
you
kind of teach yourself that to become
make it become a habit
then you should have a better game
alright hello sacrifice rook on f3 i
think that's something that
might come up long in the future but not
right now no
i do really like the idea of e5 however
i think we could prepare it a little bit
more
so i don't think e5 is bad i think e5 is
pretty cool
um probably something dwight will try to
develop
maybe e4 i guess knight moves i do think
that this position is pretty dope
but uh at the same time i feel like
black could be developing a little bit
more just a little bit
exactly the stroke on here could be in a
better place
so why not drink d8 i think rook t8 is
great uh because exactly i'm seeing
rook movement in the chat too thank you
thank you so i do that your state is
pretty cool
especially because after rook t8 you're
also kind of questioning what your
opponent wants to do and these are the
little psychological things in chess and
that's
kind of why i like to teach chess and
psychology because
you get to not just look at the moves
and do the calculations but
actually take a quick look at the
psychological
aspects of their moves too so for
example
right now we do this rook d8
it's it's not it's not just like it's
such a smart move it has such an awesome
plan coming up
but it's mainly because you're also kind
of questioning your opponent like okay
so your move
what do you want to do and your opponent
could very well make a mistake so
chess is not just over the board or like
on the computer
so you have to try and play tricky up
here too
and that's something that also did
happen to me uh quite
often when i was like when i was having
a bad game
i kept um kind of forgetting to play
tricky
i don't know if that's something that um
you could relate to
well cat's relating to it is dropping
stuff
down from the table uh thank you for
responding
but yes queen c2 exactly thank you
uh what's wrong with direct knight g4
i oh um hello
thank you for this movement
but okay um
it is quite hard to do stuff with a cat
around i do seriously have to think of
something better to do for us
championships
because otherwise we're just going to be
sitting here talking to my cat and the
arbiter and my opponent are going to be
pretty pissed
so that's that's a good
good thing to keep in mind um
so i don't think there is anything
specifically wrong
with the idea of doing a sacrifice
but one thing that i've actually learned
is you don't have to
always do a sacrifice you could simply
enjoy the x the better position that you
have so
nice g4 um first of all what if like
something like h3
to just try to kick the knight i don't
do i don't think you should be doing
this anymore
i mean you do have like an interesting
night edge too but
i don't think you should be doing that
the problem in
um the problem with sacrifices is that
if
it's not completely accurate it will
give you
give your opponents a lot of chances to
slip away
and i showed you a few of the games that
i was the one who slipped away
like i had a full piece down or i had a
bunch of
um horrifying positions i slipped away
and i drew or i won the game
so um those are some of the things that
you shouldn't do
okay glad we agree so
uh i if you want to play e5 i agree with
that but i'm
a little more interested in rook d8
and so was alejand so roof d8
and after that we can simply just kind
of chill now
queen c2 you finally push the pawn see
your kind of question you're
seeing if the opponent is scared to go
to c2
you're not forcing him uh you're just
kind of
just trying to figure out what is he
thinking like does he trust your rook d8
enough to just kind of like back away
and play queen c2
and when the opponent plays quincy too
you know that's that
your opponent knows he's worse so you
know that your opponent
already has a less psychological
advantage
so those are some of the psychological
things you could try to pull off and
then
tell me about it so all right anyways
finally we get this e5 that we wanted uh
in the game white played inaccurately
and played rook e1
i don't exactly understand this move
my guess is maybe something like wanted
to maybe bring the bishop i guess
yeah this is one of those hard moves to
figure it out yeah i
if anybody wants to tell me what they
think why uh white player jerky one feel
free to do so
otherwise a better move would be to try
to play for the center with e4
i mean it's not ideal especially because
you have d4 and now this pawn is a
monster but you at least get
some counter play you get the bishop c4
check
you get like a knight d5 uh it's still
some hope
so i do think that um i would think that
white
this would have been a better choice
just just a little bit more hope
all right so tara's for the jokey one
i'm quite surprised stark did not play
this game very well
but yeah well i guess we all have those
days
um yeah i agree most likely
this uh the bishop was the reason
not that way for this move um
yeah that's one of the things maybe he
was just intimidated by
playing verbs against all kind that
could also be
um something that does happen a lot when
you're playing
a more famous stronger player you tend
to
kind of overthink it and get in your own
head
so that's also something to try and
avoid
or if you are the stronger player you
could use that you're an advantage
i can't say i've never done that i
actually did that a few times
just because i i was stronger i
technically had more rating
i offered draw and i got out of pretty
bad positions
or yeah so those are like just some of
the little psychological stuff that you
could
do anywho
all right so we finally got this key
finally got this king pretty lonely now
i want you guys to try and tell me uh
as best as you can how as black we are
going to form an attack
keep in mind uh with this knight d2 with
the rook on
e1 if you play something like queen e5 i
think um
knight to f1 is also a possibility
g3 those two are possibilities so i
wouldn't necessarily think about
queen e5 that fast
not that queen e5 is a bad move just
like you still would need to most likely
prepare better
for it oops
i do think it's interesting to not know
who your opponent is which is a lot
about lunches you don't actually get to
see the opponent
but at the same time i i still want to
see the opponent i
trust my my brain that won't be super
intimidated
ah this is actually really funny um
i can't i think it was yesterday i told
you my sleeping skills was pretty
pretty um horrifying at the moment so i
like i
take a nap and then i wake up at weird
hours and then i can't sleep all night
but i guess we all have those um
exam weeks so i actually had a dream
that i was playing against casaro
and i was black i had two queens i
remember vividly that i had a queen on
e8 and a queen on h5
and the game somehow ended in a draw i
messed it up
and then i was like oh my god i wasn't
sharing the right screen with the
arbiter no
they're not gonna count it and i had
this anxiety
in my dream and when i woke up i was
like
huh maybe that's a that's a um
something to keep in mind for us
championships to
just be sure you're sharing the right
screen
and the right camera and all i'm
quite terrified of technological
stuff happening so yeah
that's uh i had a dream about drawing
with kasparov
when i had two queens on the board so
okay
i don't think i'm necessarily doing too
much chess actually i
should be doing more chess but okay
um
i you see that was a great dream i did
have a two queens but i don't know how
it ends in a draw if i remember it i'll
be sure just
to put a comment here i just really
don't remember i've been having weird
dreams
recently family wise too so i guess
drawing kasparov was a positive dream
we'll go but
i'll take that yeah thank you yaroslav
knight e5 my g4 is also a pretty cool
idea
you're pretty strong um i've seen you
here quite often as well
feel free to just let me know what is
your level so i have a better
understanding of
different level stats watch this streams
but yeah awesome 1985. great
i do think that i saw knight e5 knight
g4 idea earlier with
other uh other people too but i was
pretty deep in my
story with dreaming about drawing
kasparov
so sorry guys kinda overlook that
but okay so knight e5
i think it's pretty clear i think white
definitely has to do this h3
which i didn't do in the game but why
should do this h3 because
or maybe something i'm thinking can i
no the whole idea with this also gets a
little
unpleasant due to nice g4s and
f2 pawn so i don't think
i guess if you really really want to do
this um
g3 idea you could do something with my
d1
no no this is still yeah no
this is still not working so i think
actually the game night d1 was played
um but uh from what i see
is that
[Music]
i'm seeing some interesting comments uh
but no
i think h3 is the best way to go for
white
it's still quite unpleasant because
different there for a lot of different
things i just want to get this queen to
h4
so just need to get my queen in there or
i can just like a knight g6 queen e5 i
like that too
yeah just going for h2 and your g3 is
going to be super
weak also
all right
yeah i think i don't think there is a
there is a good way out of this but
let's just keep going knight e5 knight
d1
um so at the knight g4 was mentioned
earlier so i just want to take a moment
to ask
uh anybody who sees anything better than
knight g4
because i do think 94 is pretty pretty
uh pretty great
just just you got to make sure that
there's nothing better
ah that's not actually uh interesting
and
dream reading james but i don't really
have
a like a super favorite professor right
now
or like a super rival
in any of my classes i am getting pretty
whooped by
kaplan for mcat but that's about it
yeah i think you guys are doing well i
think knight g4 is good enough
uh there could be some interesting stuff
with like maybe doubling up the rook or
something like that
but i think knight g4 is just good
enough and
knight g4 pretty much have to take it
otherwise well after this in trouble
h2 is also popping open
so question what if in h3 h3 was not
played in the game i'm just asking you
guys because i'm trying to figure out
what you guys
like so easy you see uh
if we're talking the all generations i'm
gonna go with
capablanca fisher depending on which
year we're talking about but if you're
talking current chess player
since i live in san luis i'm gonna go
with fabiano
he's a pretty great chess player he's
local
why not unique hair
okay yeah i agree quinash four is
interesting
but keep in mind uh i think queenish
four
um you could it could get a little
unpleasant because take
take that the king could try to run away
so careful with that
um yeah i think you got to be careful
about that
like if check actually it's not really
getting you much
because the bishop runs away and you
don't actually have the chance to
follow up with more checks uh so if tank
you actually
have to take that with the queen which
is not the end of the world you still
you did a pretty decent sacrifice and
you still have a pretty decent attack
however a queen eshwar is not exactly
the best way to go about it
this is actually a interesting
idea to try
i guess queen is four we could try it
but after take maybe don't take back
maybe something let's move this knight
somewhere
on our tim3 i don't think it's also
working because of knight takes f3
so maybe knight d3 we're going after the
rook
take take take
check check take over here
g2 is found g4 is falling this bishop's
i
i do like this i'm gonna go for this
take that this guy's falling
the whole uh this bishop is going to
start being a monster yeah
all right look i think you guys have a
good idea and yeah
good job uh davey i think knight h2
is more interesting as well
um over here knight h2 could be a better
version of it and if you take then i
have a bunch of different ways to win i
think the knight
anywhere is great i'm just going to put
it on f3 yeah i think this is the
easiest way to win as well
all right so knight g4 in the game
bishop took g4
knight takes g4 and taurus just took a
defensive
approach and play tonight f1
so how do you guys want to continue this
attack
was a great idea yeah uh but i mean
i don't think knight h2 is that great of
an idea now
so i think bringing the queen it's time
to bring the queen we get queen of four
we get queen g3
uh g5 i got i think um either of those
should be good
yeah yeah i agree let's just bring in
the queen all right
so queen s4 i think it's interesting but
a stream maybe let's just go
right back to e5
potential of knight f3 component or an
id training opponent
but most likely you'll take that and two
bishops are pretty awesome especially
compared to these two knives those lines
are just sad
yeah you could even try d4 and keep
pushing okay this is awesome
i think winners four should be enough to
win uh in the game allah played queen g5
and i'm surprised because this game took
like
20 m um almost 20 more moves to win
so i'm not surprised on why it took so
long
because it should have been done much
earlier but
okay so
now after queen g5 white is
still trying and trying and trying
h3 so what do you want to do with your
knight
most likely wherever you go it's going
to result in a pleasant
game i guess maybe not knight takes f2
but anything besides that or taking on
e3
should be fine so
i think knight to e5 is the easiest way
to just play but you have to keep in
mind um
do you actually want to because if when
you buy an it5
definitely going to take it's not even a
question uh if you play this knight e5
opponent is going to you know
take the knight you take it back and you
have awesome two bishops
but the question should be do you want
to keep this knight because if you want
to keep this knight then you gotta play
knight h6
uh-huh i see some people are mentioning
it in the chat as well yeah
knight h6 so after knight h6
white actually played king h1
so black to move
where are we trying to go
i do agree we got to bring in more
pieces
so i'm not saying that knight e5 wasn't
good i'm just saying it take it's a
different
taste like knight e5 is awesome because
if you get knight d3 oh mama
but with knight e5 opponent is
definitely gonna
take that knight so bishop v5 bishop v5
and even though
the position is still more pleasant for
black you gotta make that decision that
do you want to keep your knight on the
board or not
all right i see a bunch of knight f5
some bishop
moving okay
bring in the rock oh maybe a rook
afternoon probably a little bit later
um
i think bringing the rooks generally is
going to be beneficial
but i don't think it's the right time
just yet
one thing that i really want to try is
d4 because d4 then if i get
d3 then my pawns are already also
quite monstrous but i can't exactly do
this d4 right now
i mean i guess i can but um
and it would get it would give quite
some chances
of trying to you know slip away and i
don't
i don't like slippery opponents
or actually let's just move the king i
guess still
i don't i don't want slippery opponents
yeah
so i think d4 is a little too early to
do so in order to do d4
then we could do this knight f5 that was
mentioned by
multiple of the people in chat
so yeah i think that's another great way
to go about it
so
in the game white played knight h2
which i i kind of get it like you gotta
do something your position is not
actually that pretty so you have to move
something
but i don't think knight issue is
actually the best way
um
i guess knight h2's idea was if you
played knight h4 i would play rook g1
but i mean position is not quite
pleasant
anyways and i know i keep saying that
but i don't think the position is
getting any better
so now what we're trying to figure out
is just how to win this game
we know we're better that's not the
question anymore
so black to me what do you think we
should do
should they still try to push for d4
should we um try to bring more pieces
into king side
and stop chess.com that just
uh i do agree that black should
eventually try to
use the advantage in the f file so
i agree bishop c8 is also pretty cool
something with bishop c8
something with rook f7 try and double up
i think all of those are
decent
knight g3 huh
i think the problem with knight g3 could
be the fact
that first of all he doesn't have to
take it
because if he takes it then you take
with the queen and h2 is quite
hard to actually keep but king g1
[Music]
what is your follow-up that's what i'm
trying to figure out
i blackness is still much much better
just
how are you trying to follow up that's
what i'm trying to figure out
and i'm having a little um hard time
actually figuring that out maybe you
could try to double up
but i don't think you necessarily have
to have that nikon g3
so i am a fan of d4 to be honest i think
d4
is the easiest way to win why would you
sit here and calculate all the ways you
could attack the king when you can
you know just get so much space that the
king is just gonna
just not wanna even
try to move so i think d4
psychologically is
even more um just showing up your power
showing off your space showing off your
how you're dominating the opponent i
think all of these
are um ways to consider it
but all right so um
i believe in the game taraj played
bishop c1 which
just looks pretty weird but i honestly
don't know what else to do for whites
i mean i guess
is there a check could i take this and
try to give a check
yeah this is not very appealing also
rooks get doubled up
you take over here i also have rook c8
how are you going to defend this poor
guy
yeah i don't i don't really um
oh boy also that gets opened up yeah
that's pretty horrible yep
i am not going to want to take that
pawns white either
so bishop c1 i mean i understand that
the threats
that okay i want to take this and eat
your i want to eat this and attack your
queen
but i don't think uh it's very realistic
to be honest
so um bishop c1
and so blackstone what do you want to do
you have some choices
you could consider a bunch of checks
you could consider you know pushing over
here
you could probably even still consider
just moving the queens maybe just queen
g6
i'm pretty sure this is also winning so
you have a bunch of options
just which one do you think is
best most accurate most oh hold on let
me rephrase my question
which one do you think is most annoying
for the opponents
um i think d3 also yeah
i see a knight is four okay i think that
h4 is interesting as well
again i don't really see anything
specific really
wrong with any of these moves as long as
you're not blundering you're fine
but at the same time
d series seems pretty pretty
uh pretty awesome so
okay d3
and
all right so i see there are a lot of
great comments
all right awesome
gotta move the king so now black to move
what do you think we should do
[Music]
yeah i kind of cut maybe two three
inches of my hair today
that was a little bored and i was trying
to
not study so i cut some hair
i don't know if i regret it just yet
still pretty long but
um i don't think it's time to the rookie
of six i don't really want to
i don't want to give up my rook like i
get that you want to bring your rook
but i guess bishop b2's whole idea was
to avoid this
take away this undercap 6.
so you see ben simon is writing
celebration but it's more like come here
for
all the juicy detail so
i'm sure there'll be clips of it on the
internet
but yeah oh hi josh ah
you're just on time for some good old
night tanking
what major do i study um a bunch of them
i am doing biology health sciences and
health care ethics so
yeah it's fun um i don't think knight e3
is exactly what we had in mind because
knight takes e3
this i think this is the one move that
white could actually get better with
rook takes e3 and you don't really have
a follow-up if the pawn to
okay yes uh no questions there that's
why it's
why it's pretty busted i agree knight g3
yep uh-huh 93
and the beauty of it is that remember
how exactly oh good job thank you for
making my life easier for putting stuff
in that chat too
uh remember how earlier when we talked
about where was it you talked about
knight's g3 quite earlier we talked
about this knight g3 idea
ah here before the pawn was on d3
and we said if king goes to g1 then we
don't really have a follow-up
so that is why right now this 92 would
be pretty awesome because well first of
all if you take it
muchas gracias give me that knight and
the mate
as well uh if you
don't take it now i do have this knight
e2 whenever i want it nobody's rushing
me because if take i'll still take that
no problem there um
so now black timon what do you think we
should do
that's interesting i'm i'm quite curious
wouldn't white
have a knight g4 at the end to try and
defend h2
yeah i think that might be a little bit
problematic if you try to do like a
quick knight um quick like knight d2 or
f2 i think that's
why it's not necessarily the best way to
go about it
but still our h4s so
i mean it's worth looking at but i think
i think these are like extra
stuff that could give your opponents the
chance to actually slip away
and they don't really want to do that
ooh this g7 pum
is also beginning to
yeah queen f7 oh boy yeah why it's much
better now
let's not do this i don't want to give
my opponent chances to
whoop me i'm getting enough whooping
from kaplan and mcat studying
no need for people from 100 years ago
two of me too
so no 92 i don't think 92 is accurate
just yet
but we could bring more pieces
maybe why not bishop d5 also also we
just mentioned something with queen f7
right so let's just do bishop d5 so we
never ever ever have to worry about this
and okay you gotta move the queen queen
c3 uh
i'm gonna do this 92 right so you have
very
limited numbers of squares to go for
example if you go queen a
four what do you think we should do now
so black to move how are we winning
it is quite sad not questions there
so these are some of the ideas that have
been mentioned pretty frequently
earlier
i'm not the biggest fan of bishop e6 i
kind of like my bishop where it is
maybe d2 looks interesting it means
you're eating
extra material i'm not gonna stop you
from that
yeah i guess this is just good enough
yeah i guess d2 is good enough all right
since we have d2 i'm just going to go
ahead
and show you um what was played in the
game
so allah played knight e2 king h1
and finally this is the move that has
been mentioned a bunch of times
brick epsilon so we are simply trying to
double up we're finally bringing our
other rook oh my god just
took what like 30 moves to bring that
truck
okay uh another another little also
psychological
thing to keep in mind is not overdoing
it you shouldn't
always be looking at to sacrifice yes
it's fun
to sacrifice your adrenaline goes high
your blood is bumping
your heart is racing your eyes get big
but the
yeah we don't really necessarily need um
sacrifice
we don't we shouldn't be looking into um
unnecessary sacrifices so
exactly thank you josh that is a
psychological way to do it and
it's like psychological torture maybe i
should change the name of this course
um uh
so yeah i think it's it's a game yeah we
should have fun
but it doesn't mean we have to have fun
and you know
give our opponent a chance to sleep away
we could have fun
by like getting the opponents like
pretty miserable
not sledding uh like not technically a
zugzwang
but still it's still kind of a kind of a
zug's one like you don't really have any
good moves anyways like right now
but you're also not in a real too so
long yeah i did cut my hair a little bit
but it wasn't spontaneous it was more
like it was quite uh strategic i was
trying to kill time before the stream
so i didn't have to study see
yeah exactly you could just enjoy this
fantastic position instead of giving you
material
to unclear exactly oh okay i think you
guys are doing this pretty awesome
all right thank you oh thank you james
that's very nice of you to say so
all right so let me try to wrap this up
i do not want
the uh dennis bars to have to sit on all
the secrets and scandals for much longer
so in the game actually elephant played
h5 again there are
many many many ways to win this so
just do what makes the most sense to you
and but don't give up
stuff unless you actually see absolute
clear advantage
i feel like sacrificing and just playing
normal after sacrifice
is just something that you see in movies
i mean in
like super high chess players so
unless you're one of those which i don't
know what you're doing here
then i don't recommend you do that so
sorry josh kind of overlooked you but
you can sacrifice as much as you want
i'm not gonna stop you but
okay so h5
and like see white is doing like uh
desperate thrives with b6
and now allah is like all right i'm
gonna try this
well if you take that's going to be mate
you don't even really have that knight
g4
after because of the pawn and
chain g1 i just take back not even
giving any chance no chance
even though a8 wasn't actually working
because you have pieces but no chance
and take now finally this d2 we could
have left
d2 much earlier too and
all right let's eat that and i'm gonna
come over here
attack on h3 it's just such a chill way
to attack
and i do think that being too chill is
also not
the best way um so yeah
just try your best not to be too chill
or
something like okay now this makes sense
right take
or kf3 and this is pretty lost right
knight f3 knight g3 just h4
this guy is falling i actually i can't
think of any way for
white god this is funny huh the only
thing is if you take with the pawn i'm
gonna take care okay that was actually
cute
nice try um just take this the queen and
just
give that checkmate and this uh that's
actually
in this position the game ended however
if you play something like kg1 i have
bishopvish two and mates coming up
quite soon um if you don't like kng2
i'm gonna have like queen of three
that's also next movement
so yeah i think this was a pretty
interesting game
also because um it was quite dynamic and
it doesn't
just promote the idea of attack attack
attack it
promotes the idea of making your
opponent uncomfortable
and psychological torture and
stuff like that so all right
on that note i am going to
uh wish you a great night i'm gonna
invite you to watch dennis boris's
spilled beans
segment and i am gonna go get some
coffee
and do the rest of my neuroscience
uh i'll see you guys on friday
so tune in for from my friday lessons
have fun